welcome to this video on playing black
against Pablo Pizarro from Argentina
let's see hmm it's played probably this
he had this weird line with e4 pretty
similar to him the black Medina gambit
I simply ignored it going to a French
type of structure that's not the best
way to play but I don't like to to face
this kind of wacky opening rather play a
close game here f5 shutting down okay
it's rather typical sometimes of those
get a bit Thai players they they really
can't stand to have a closed position
and want to open it up even when it's
not really a good idea
Wow you give up your dark-squared bishop
here that's quite remarkable okay yeah
it's very much weakening the dark
squares that's probably not a good idea
Queen here maybe and so there more than
one good idea Jack yeah here must why I
don't mind moving the King the bishop on
b5 is just a liability and the King on
f7 is is okay okay just Bishop here I
guess he might play Knight to b3 though
yeah it's still not bad
the knight on v3 is not a great piece I
can just drop back to the six attacking
f4 and he cannot castle which is the
general problem
cannot castle him okay yeah this check
on g5 on e5 okay that's just free up GG
the g8 square for the king he cannot
castle on that's the main point here
then at some point threatening a six if
he plays 92 for example a six is just
good okay maybe I should do this no
Bishop d3 now being forced I guess see
see planning or no before I can put the
bishop here let's get out of this check
if he goes before I also have a Bishop
e3
yeah that's really a wild position
whereas whatever going to have a safe
King position I guess he just won't have
a good King position in the game short
castles not possible and long well you
have played before and all those moves
let's see maybe just a shape t7 and rook
c8 taking the c3 pawn I completely
forgot about this move it's a very
simple move but I just forgot about it
great Knight g4 probably
now you might have Bishop 87 no I simply
I simply relax too early
can give the shakers wrong yeah probably
must do that no King edge to rock edge
too
I can take Bishop c1 and Bishop b5 so
what the wacky stuff now he's doing that
take it 95 King g6 what exactly is going
on here I don't know jack I mean I even
overlooked the simple Knight see to move
I probably have overlooked even more
but I don't see what he's doing now
maybe I mean the rook is just hanging
yeah maybe he's got the got an attack
yeah that's possible with queen g4 but I
don't see it
I mean on e3 is just have has a knight
hanging Jack don't have any seven at the
end you can go to yourself
Quincy Bond is also a threat him long
castle me yeah well if I ever checked
myself I mean I cannot believe that Jess
shouldn't be winning
yeah should be fly it with the check
this must be helpful
when night g3 check was probably even
better I am check
check okay this should be a made somehow
whoopsies free check hmm yeah come on
let's win the Queen first white reason
way we'll look so much stuff in this
game I rather than the Queen eeeh
what the I mean around here black should
be should be fled out winning with
castling here that this is just just
totally dominating white but I've played
it played it badly
I mean this night this night a three
night a three to see to the computer was
played deform directly trying to open up
the position probably that is right I
mean I didn't really think about that
much because of c4 closing everything
but I have b6 and the exact opposite
thing is happening I'm opening up the
position hmm Knight e3 again and they
also have this I mean it's really hard
to believe that this should be any good
Bishop age seven are still very murky
hmm maybe Bishop d6 was stronger that's
very much possible and if he protects it
maybe then d4 because this is just a
very good for black
yeah very hard very hard to play okay
let's let's look at at this probably
probably I have a problem here yeah he
could have taken you I thought that much
with my g5 I probably have to move the
King and then again Knight g5 amazing
yeah Jack Jack yeah and this is it seems
not working like a swinging I wasn't
totally sure it's so very very working
but here black is Winningham - five okay
boy at least something we worked out
right him it seems that here like he
isn't so so much better than a thought I
mean this looks terrible with the bishop
only three but maybe it is not that bad
it's tough to analyze with this limited
time but it's clearly you far more
complicated than it appears at first
sight
alright thanks for watching